I am hungry but I'm always hungry so I
guess there's really matter if I
mentioned that I'm hungry
I got a pull but that I think I always
have to so hey what's going on YouTube
[ __ ] that free kick I just want a quick
little bite trail so I feel all
energized I feel love you know with your
there will be a time where I won't be
able to grab these titties anymore but
until then she wouldn't be so recently I
was set a very interesting article
apparently a Chinese Romeo was faced
with a dilemma when his current
girlfriend and his ex-girlfriend both
jumped off a bridge to see who she would
save first
or as they say in China is a tale of one
dragon and poop on me ready well ain't
you jet the Love Machine you did the
love I did that last week too huh now if
you don't know already I am in my
mid-20s and yes I happen to love the
phone and trust me I do understand that
love can make you do crazy things for
example one time I was with my
girlfriend and I was eating a double
cheeseburger and she asked for a bite
and and I said yes
did I want to that's none of your
[ __ ] business now this just might be
me but if you jump off a bridge to test
my love you just jumped off a bridge
[ __ ] my dad I will watch both your dumb
asses plummet to your death and support
you from a distance I hope you had dumb
[ __ ] haha listen just because you put
your life in danger to test my love it
does not mean I should put mine in
danger for you hmm because the point
that I'm making here is that you did
this on purpose to test me it's not
danger that just naturally can your way
okay cuz yes let's say we were on
vacation right we're in Africa and
there's Sully from a bush a rabid
gorilla taxi yes I might do something a
gorilla you wanna Panetta you know
looking at this article I want to feel
bad for the guy but I know because based
on your track record it seemed like you
got a thing for crazy because unless you
the worst luck on earth what are the
chances that you would date two girls
that actually think solving relationship
problems are done by drowning yourself
[ __ ] there are other ways to solve your
relationship problems like I don't know
talking about it having a level
conversation is the key to great
communication and every girl that I
dated we have communicated quite well
baby I'm gonna have lunch with my ex is
that cool oh so you don't want to have
sex anymore
why are you not saying like that and on
top of that nobody likes to be in a
relationship when your significant other
always test your love if I know from a
dream would you save me my love book I
will you guide me what why are you
constantly in danger what are you doing
in your life that you are constantly
falling out of trees poking your
eyeballs out [ __ ] you look clumsy
[ __ ] honestly at that point you
don't need me what you need is a sense
of balance and a pair of glasses could
[ __ ] you lost you'll realize that both
of you are so insecure that you actually
jump off a bridge and do the
ex-girlfriend that showed up on the
bridge and is still following your
ex-boyfriend after four months you are
not in love you stupid as hell for you
to test a relationship that does not
exist prove that you are the cleanest
[ __ ] on earth here's my advice
to you get over it and move on because
as you know there is a shortage of
single women in China and let me tell
you something get yourself some new bit
and hold on tight what look dude
according to the picture it seemed like
you jumped after one of them or
something like that
if I was you I would never [ __ ] I want
to throw in two floaties and a [ __ ]
Bible cuz those [ __ ] need Jesus
ah I will watch you I'll watch you bye
what's new chicken god damn it you know
looking at this article from an
objective perspective while that round
what are the chances that you would date
two girls that think that receptor that
I wouldn't heard or not win immensely
win in any way every girl that I dated
while we commit you need to know anyone
who need is this [ __ ] even in focus
focus